[Music]
but first at least 12 people are
reported dead in an apparent bomb attack
on a police headquarters in Pakistan two
explosions went off inside the heavily
fortified counter-terrorism building in
the northern SWAT District the area used
to be a stronghold of the Pakistani
Taliban Kama Haider is keeping an eye
out on that story joining us from
Islamabad so that death toll is creeping
up Kamal
indeed the police sources have informed
Al Jazeera that 12 people are so far
confirmed or killed in that deadly twin
bombing we are told that there were two
explosions and 40 people have been
wounded now this happening on a compound
which is just across the river from the
main city of mingawara SWAT of course is
about 233 kilometers from Islamabad this
is a fairly well defended compound so
inside that compound which is about 10
hectares there's the counter-terrorism
department which was the main target of
the attack there is a police training
facility there several senior police
officials have their offices there so
indeed there will be questions as to how
these people were able to penetrate
inside but the attack took place off the
dock after the sunset and that of course
made the matter even more complicated
because carrying out any effort to
rescue or recover anybody from that
debris which of course according to
reports the roof collapsed and the
people may be still buried under that
Rubble so indeed the police now
confirming that 12 people have been
killed 40 people have been wounded all
right Kamal thank you for that update
from Islamabad